hello would welcome to this video
playing swap one of my somewhat
uncomfortable opponents I always have
problems against them I don't really
know why oh is that ended sin to opening
normally play some c6 waste openings and
trying on things like later at the
National aston villa okay try that line
to see if it goes 94 that's a Phi the
time that I'm playing this line no he
doesn't okay yeah it's somewhat passive
way to play let's go here how to do that
Roxy one maybe over to 84 I guess
maybe with that one to threaten f3 not
quite clear the other night also made
some sense ok St does he have to do
something about f3 or is there some
tactical way to do that like queen bee
six or something along these lines
sometimes there are funny tactics these
kind of positions I don't see it though
Queen B 6 f3a six something like that it
looks completely completely mad my might
work yep is going for it yes that
sometimes is kind of provocative style
okay
so f 3 is going a six
okay if I just take c6 Queen B 5 this 94
that's good for me you will take with
the a paw down and then 90 for the c-5a
6 is threatened down
all right what do we get position and it
takes time to take time like madman him
before we can just go Bishop age five
aged 3 didn't didn't help at all I
really hated when miracle moves like
Queen B 6 work em they just ignore f3
and play all those super light you for
everything playing to the maximum and
then Queen B 6 just prevents f3m so that
you don't have to retreat stuff yeah but
if it works it works i mean at least i
didn't see why i drilled well is the
next miracle move damn h3 was something
that spoon okay it wasn't strictly
necessary and why is that possible
because of that pin
unbelievable yeah I don't know against
this guy always have those weird games
where you place I mean I'm playing
probably just an idiot but it just finds
all those great moves I don't know maybe
should be five is not particularly
difficult to see but I was simply
stunned here what happens
you
Wow Queen B 6 and below the h3 was
really a stupid move when I was kind of
kind of stunned that this just worked
look at c2 not resigning yeah yes also
history of screwing up those positions
against me so I'm not just resigning
definitely not
Queenie to kingdom one and I've got some
threats now not if Queenie five was not
necessary at all hmm that isn't clear at
all I might find here maybe what is this
move now Queenie five was a stupid idea
okay I can take g7 now but disinterred
doesn't win that's got cringy say hi
Martin but you got Queen g6
unfortunately look you won that a move I
is got Queen g6 it isn't it isn't it
isn't work okay still as Queen g6 bit
I is attacking my night it's something I
was seeing that his night is hanging
here unbelievable what a game okay come
on what resign what not even that
entirely bad move Queenie fire fear
could could screw that up this is just
saving the staving the whole thing yeah
what what what a bad game what did I do
wrong here so this is a position where
watches it's just a little bit better
and I couldn't prove it at all yeah 90
for such a super ambitious move of
course they're just and now queen bee 6
just ignoring f3m believer now the
engine says I can still play it but it's
some yeah it's not what you want and no
Queen d3 and that is actually pretty
decent for wide and I didn't see that
idea that's what I have to do yeah okay
I was a bit too too stunned somehow the
tea that he found this idea you know and
now this is just bad him 93 is just
wrong why didn't see that move yeah yeah
I'm lost em I just try to irritate him
and it worked a little bit here you also
kind of irritated but I cannot do
anything him he's covered age six and if
i take g7 he's got Queen g6 and this is
the end of this end of story no solve it
was a very well deserved wind for black
so what do I have to do here I mean this
has a pretty terrible reputation laying
like that or maybe I should switch to
Bishop g5 still I really don't know that
that should be bad really maybe around
here I have to improve them
maybe you have to do this I mean there
are ideas like simply try to get that
pawn yeah that that seems to be okay can
also go 85 here yeah that's just bad
okay that was a good win for him thanks
for watching